et bienvenue sur tv fil 78 pour le 7-8
il est 18 heures si vous nous rejoignez
en direct et nous allons une nouvelle
fois faire le tour de l'actualité locale
au cours de la prochaine heure voici les
titres de ce 21 février à prendre lé
règle de droit a dû et travailler les
nouveautés en la matière tout en
s'amusant le principe du jeu de l'emploi
cela s'est déroulé à guyancourt dans le
cadre de la semaine de l'emploi
la librairie populaire du millefeuille à
des ménages y allait dorénavant installé
dans de nouveaux locaux à côté de la
gare de trappes toujours le même
principe proposer des livres d'occasion
à bas coûts et offrir à ses salariés une
possibilité de réinsertion
le parc du poirier est saint martin à
montigny le bretonneux en pleine
réhabilitation mais pas n'importe
comment un chantier qui s'inscrit dans
une vocation écologique avec la
réalisation notamment d'une mare et puis
en sport du hand féminin plaisir
accueilli ce mercredi le quart de finale
de la coupe de la ligue le havre a battu
d'un point le club de mios biganos 26 à
à noter surtout que dans le club havrais
évoluer linda pradel la gardienne de ce
club
elle est native de trappes et puis comme
chaque jeudi au cours de cette suite
nous ferons le point sur l'économie à la
chronique de l'écho avec claire cambier
bonsoir clair bonsoir wifried bonsoir à
tous le salon de l'agriculture débute ce
week-end nous allons nous parler
agriculture dans sa chronique et plus
particulièrement du produire et
consommer local nous verrons les
intérêts économiques et les limites de
ce mode de fonctionnement
ça s'appelle les circuits courts c'est à
dire quand il ya 1 ou pas deux
intermédiaires entre le consommateur et
le producteur
pour cela nous recevrons le responsable
de la boutique gourmande de la bergerie
nationale de rambouillet et
l'agriculteur de la ferme de viltain à
jouy en josas
le salon de l'agriculture avant l'heure
à tout à l'heure clair pour cette
chronique de l'éco je reçois pour
l'instant sur ce plateau christine qui
avait un bon soir et vincent dieudonné
vous êtes responsables chacun étaient
des scouts alors d'une partie des scouts
et guides de france de votre côté des
scouts d'europe vous allez nous dire ce
que signifie être scout alors que demain
à 22 février ce sera la journée mondiale
du
scoutisme auparavant je vous propose de
vous rendre tout de suite du côté de
trappes pour découvrir ses nouveaux
locaux de la librairie le millefeuille
qui poursuit sa vocation de réinsertion
sociale
ça déménage à la librairie mille
feuilles de trappes
la boutique solidaire a quitté son petit
local situé près de la nationale pour
s'installer au 23 de la rue pierre
sémard dans une ancienne maison de la
presse
à deux pas de la gare désormais la
responsable emilie bertrand bénéficie
d'une vitrine passante et d'un espace
mieux agencé pour accueillir sa
clientèle
autre nouveauté l'aménagement d'un
espace jeunesse de 20 m² l'espace ici il
est fait de façon à ce que les
alors on a conçu exprès pour que les
mamans puissent installer avec les
petits les mamans ou les papas avec les
plus petits pendant que les grands
vadrouille en fait sur le reste de la
salle donc c'est vrai que ça ça
fonctionne bien et ce après beaucoup les
enfants adorent venir ici ça ça ça
marche bien qu'ils aient leur lieu au
6ème bien les apprécier dès que les
beaux jours arriveront des lectures de
contes devrait être organisé dans le
jardin attenant au total ce sont 70 m²
dédiés à près de cinquante mille livres
d'occasion récupérer auprès de
particuliers et médiathèques du
territoire saint quentinois en partie
avec toujours la même politique de prix
compétitifs de 50 centimes le livre de
poche à 2 3 euros le grand format et
entre 5 et 10 euros le beau livre
l'autre spécificité de la librairie
mille feuilles et d'être un chantier
d'insertion une équipe de 12 personnes
bénéficient de contrats aidés financés
par l'état parmi eux ceux trappistes
chargé de mettre en vente une sélection
de livres de la boutique sur internet
on a de la chance quand même des trous
l'ont trahi comme ça ça nous permet de
nous remettre un branchement et beaucoup
de soutiens prendre un besoin pour moi
de discuter père de famille il aimerait
travailler dans la petite enfance
car l'objectif des contrats aidés et de
servir de tremplin pour s'insérer dans
la vie active des projets accompagnés
par une conseillère en insertion
professionnelle ainsi qu'une psychologue
pour ses douze employés au parcours de
vie parfois difficile ça peut être des
personnes qui ont en fait des accidents
de vie
ça peut être des problèmes de santé pour
la plupart ils ont connu un chômage de
longue durée ou n'ont jamais travaillé
en france donc avec des difficultés
aussi pour certains de maîtriser
parfaitement la langue française
la librairie populaire et convivial
prend également soin de son public
elle accueillera dominique sampiero le
20 mars dans le cadre du printemps des
poètes le scoutisme un mouvement de la
jeunesse créé au début du 20e siècle 38
millions de membres estimés à travers le
monde plusieurs associations portent ses
valeurs notamment les scouts et guides
de france et les scouts d'europe nous en
avons bon cru deux représentants sur ce
plateau de représentants dans le
département bonsoir donc à tous les deux
et demain 22 février journée mondiale du
scoutisme et je donnais quelques
chiffres en voici un autre 69000 c'est
le nombre d'adhérents france au
mouvement des scouts et guides de france
christine kéribin combien êtes vous dans
les yvelines
et puis quelle évolution aussi ces
dernières années alors dans les yvelines
nous sommes environ quatre mille deux
cents adhérents avec une évolution
croissante à peu près de 3 4% par an ce
moment quand ya pas d en tout cas de
perte d'intérêt autour des noces ou non
je dirais même qu'il ya plutôt un regain
d'intérêt pour ces notions on connaît
peut-être un petit peu moins les scouts
d'europe en revanche été défini et puis
comme je vous le confirme cette tendance
que christine vient de vient d'annoncer
donc il ya une progression de nouveau
nous sommes dans les yvelines
5200 en ce moment et au moment des camps
il ya toujours une augmentation vers la
fin de l'année 5500 général guides et
scouts la photo ne vous posez cette
question pour ce soit bien clair scouts
d'europe et scouts et guides de france
quelle est la différence
est ce qu'il ya de différent seulement
déjà je pense qu'à une ressemblance qui
est que nous proposons le scoutisme aux
enfants de scoutisme fondamentale avec
des notions comme la vie dans la nature
la vie en équipe la loi la promesse je
pense que ce sont des valeurs que nous
partageons
après je connais pas très bien les les
scouts et guides d'europe mais je pense
qu'il ya au moins
de premier abord une idée que nous avons
quatre tranches d'âge et qui me semble
que vous n'avez que trois tranches d'âge
nous nous avons deux tranches d'âge
d'entre 8 ans et 11 ans les louveteaux
jeannettes puis les scouts guides entre
11 et 14
les pionniers caravelles entre 14 et 17
et puis la branche aînée au dessus là la
différence jusque dans les catégories
d'âge je crois qu'il faut d'abord redire
insister sur le fait que le scoutisme
faut camper le décor c'est un c'est une
éducation par le jeu et nous avons en
commun chacun décline un peu de sa façon
mais c'est une éducation active le
garçon apprend garçons et à la fille à
se prendre en main nous voir mener sa
barque acteur véritablement de strider
de sa propre vie basé sur des méthodes
de pédagogie active
on va pas développer ça maintenant et
donc je crois que c'est important de
dire on a ça en commun mais dans un
contexte collectif
donc on a ça en commun bien entendu tous
les scouts du monde là le groupe avec
une identité en commun et c'est dans ce
groupe que ce s'épanouit l'individu
enfin en l'occurrence le jeune voilà
donc il faut qu'il aille vers sa vie de
femmes et d'hommes je crois que là de ça
alors est-ce que vous travaillez
ensemble à ce que chacun travaille dans
son coin je dirais que nous avons des
relations fraternelles entre scouts
france scouts et guides de france et
guides et scouts d'europe en particulier
on a pu le montrer lors de la demande il
est mineur voilà exactement
donc après cotisé de soins tels
2006-2007 qui correspondait d'ailleurs
150e anniversaire de la naissance de
baden powell parce qu'il faut quand même
dire que le 22 février auxquelles vous
faisiez allusion qui est demain c'est le
jour anniversaire de baden powell
quénéhen 22 février 1857 et il avait
exactement 50 ans quand il a lancé le
scoutisme ans
1907 en 1907 ils ont perdu son épouse
aussi qui est né le même jour
scouts de france qui sont
complémentaires vous le voyez dans les
explications qui sont apportées ce soir
donc vous le disiez un total à tout à
l'heure à l'origine ça à était créer
véritablement pour que les jeunes soient
acteurs de leur éducation est ce qu'il
ya eu des changements en un siècle un
peu plus d'un siècle qu'est ce qui a
changé dans la notion même de scoutisme
est dans la façon d'aborder le scoutisme
alors je vais déjà dire une chose qui
importe pour nous c'est effectivement
les trois les trois tranches d'âge et un
mot la patrouille qui est un
regroupement de six sept huit filles ou
garçons autour du plus âgé ou du plus
compétents d'entre eux pour justement
recréer cette base et sur l'instinct de
bande
la petite collectivité dans laquelle
chacun va pouvoir prendre une
responsabilité donc il ya un mot à
retenir ses responsabilités dans la
patrouille ça ces notes c'est pas notre
spécificité c'est celle que baden powell
on a créé il ya cent ans et qu'on a
qu'on garde jalousement et qui est
importante pour nous et qu'on ne veut
pas changer
et après au delà de s'inscrire une
évolution justement dans la façon de
faire aussi dans les réflexions qui sont
avait pour rester en phase aussi avec
l'époque et effectivement donc nous on
considère que c'est important de rester
en phase avec son époque
effectivement on a des réflexions
régulière sur la pédagogique que l'on
met dans nos différentes branches
ça peut être les l'imaginaire qui évolue
un petit peu par exemple dans chacune
des branches ça peut être aussi le
spectre des projets qui sont proposés et
qui s'adapte à des problèmes de la
société
que signifie être scout pour le grand
public on va juste écouter ces quelques
réponses et puis vous pourrez réagir
ensuite j'ai fait du scoutisme quand
j'étais jeune
briens la bonne quarantaine d'années
quoi aujourd'hui je pense que c'est bon
d'avoir des repères l'autisme et à une
structure tout à fait adéquat pour
donner un repère à pas mal de jeunes
ça représente
pour les enfants quelque chose de très
bien parce que ça les fait sortir
d'eux-mêmes et penser aux autres
j'en ai fait ça m'a pas plu du tout il y
a deux souhaits this mais est ce que tu
sais les scouts européens et les scouts
et scouts de france papa personnel moi
je préfère les scouts de france trouve
que c'est pas mal
le scoutisme c'est ici c'est encore ça à
mon époque c'était l'apprentissage de la
vie c'était l'esprit des clips c'était
savoirs partagés
c'était ça représentait beaucoup de
chercher parce que c'est toujours la
même valeur de nos jours mais pourquoi
pas si ça l'aide tant mieux il ya deux
choses dans la dernière intervention
déjà la surprise à cette question est ce
que le scoutisme ça existe toujours donc
vous demander si vous n'avez pas
l'impression que c'est aussi désuet mais
même si vous m'avez déjà un petit peu
répondu tout à l'heure en parlant du
nombre d'inscriptions et puis l'autre
chose c'est aussi sur les valeurs qui
sont véhiculées alors tout d'abord sur
le fait que ce soit
désuet peut-être surprenant que ça
existe encore alors faut retenir une
chose le scoutisme est basé sur la
première qualité de l'enfant que
reconnaissait baden powell c'est
l'observation souci de l'observation du
réel
et ça ça il faut que ça évolue parce
qu'aujourd'hui on est dans un monde
virtuel
il faut absolument retrouver les
réflexes et analysé observer le réel ça
en le fond dit dans le vestiaire de
l'actualité c'est très d'actualité
une deuxième chose qui est basé
complètement là tu sais la nature retour
à la nature en fête les scouts ne
revienne par la nature et qui ont été
depuis le début et nous avons été
précurseurs de l'écologie nous sommes
profondément écologiste aujourd'hui bien
avant l'heure les premiers à sortir à un
vélo en forêt c'était les scouts les
premiers allaient camper faire découvrir
la nature et l'observer l'admirer
c'était les scouts aujourd'hui on a
aussi deux longueurs d'avancé dans un
certain nombre de domaines
donc oui non seulement le scout ça
existe encore mais c'est complètement
prophétique
voilà donc je confirme effectivement que
le fait de d'éduquer les enfants à mieux
habiter leur planète c'est un cetain
sont des valeurs que l'on veux leur
transmettre mais aussi des valeurs de
solidarité que l'on souhaite leur
transmettre et ça c'est parfaitement
d'actualité des valeurs d'autonomie qui
sont qui sont importantes et qu'on
essaie de
enfin on essaie de les éduquer au fur et
à mesure à l'autonomie on parle d' être
scout aujourd'hui en 2013 ce que cela
signifie on va retourner quelques années
en arrière 1985 et ce film mon cousin
forcément par les scouts toujours on va
juste en voir un extrait jaurès ou même
votre réaction savoir si cette image là
qu'il existe encore des scouts vous a
pénalisé le regard que vous portez sur
ce sur ce film qui était sorti en 1985
c'est très gentil l'ont accompagné dans
une romance à se dire au revoir c'est
vraiment quand j'ai démarré tout moment
ne pas repenser raclette pas tous pas
très bien timé crime promis je te
raconterai
qu'ils sortent leur histoire aussi il va
pas se marier battant les gens à changer
les idées
et ce scout un gérard jugnot terrorisé
par ses enfants est ce que cette image
véhiculée dans les années 80 ça vous a
pesé quel regard vous avez porté sur ce
film la dérision peut avoir du bon
gérard jugnot et est le boute en train
dans sa troupe qui était je prends la
première versailles
il était buteur trace un petit peu
dommage qu'il n'ait dîner donné une
image du scoutisme dans son film que de
l'horreur de la dérision sur le
scoutisme est étonné étonnamment absent
du cinéma il est encore très présent
dans la littérature dans les livres qui
font rêver les jeunes ce qu'il faut
donner aux rêves
enfin aux jeunes pardon c'est du rêve et
là c'est dommage que j'ai rangé avec
tout le talent qu'il avait notamment sa
troupe scoute ne l'est pas faire
refléter plus dans le film mais
peut-être qu'il ya un temps pour tout ça
a vécu les mauvaises images
aujourd'hui encore vous la santé oui
c'est vrai que de temps en temps on
ressent cette mauvaise image mais
quelque part il suffit de d'inviter des
enfants dans nos unités pour voir ce qui
s'y passe et pour qu'ils comprennent que
c'est pas ce qui se passait dans le film
sort ce film était une comédie en tout
même ce n'était pas un documentaire
autour du bourg être que les choses
soient tout de même bien clair il ya une
notion importante en dans le scoutisme
dont on n'a pas parlé c'est aussi la
croyance l'aspect religieux quelle place
à ok aujourd'hui nous sommes une
association catholique donc
effectivement nous proposons d'annoncer
les janvier l'évangile à nos adhérents
mais nous sommes aussi une association
ouverte à tous donc nous avons des
enfants non baptisés nous avons des
enfants musulmans et le principe aussi
étant de les éduquer la spiritualité
comment ça se traduit du côté des scouts
d'europe la verticalité la spiritualité
est extrêmement importante nous la
portant sur l'uniforme
nous essayons d'en vivre il est évident
qu'il ya par exemple dans la branche
aînée chez nous
on essaie de mettre en place les
proposer les accompagnements avec par un
civil et par un religieux pour qu'ils
aient une véritable prise de conscience
à l'âge mûr dix ans
de cette spiritualité et chacun la vie
du mieux qu'il peut notre but c'est pas
de faire des catégories de s'éprendre
des garçons et des filles qui ont envie
de vivre un idéal commun et de les
développer de léser panneaux et encore
une fois chacun selon leur dos et c'est
vrai que certains dans le séminaire de
versailles à un certain nombre d'anciens
scouts et notamment annoncé un nombre de
scouts d'europe mais il n'y a pas du
tout de formatage
on est plutôt dans l'épanouissement des
dons il se trouve que les filles ne
regarderais qui justement a envie
d'inscrire ses enfants pour justement
véhiculer toutes ses valeurs et à
prendre toutes ces valeurs
par exemple la bienvenue et elle est
respectée avec bienveillance avec avec
ce qu'elle apporte
nous avons des démarches d'accueil de
effectivement n'obtenons baptisé du
moment qu'ils puissent adhérer aux
autres valeurs et nous essayons de les
emmener vers sa percée vers cette
découverte de la spiritualité
dernière question vous avez évoqué
l'uniforme tout à l'heure vous avez
chacun l'uniforme donc scouts et guides
de france
et puis et scouts d'europe ça traduit
quoi sur le l'uniforme d'un scout que
barbie signification je crois que vous
voyez qu'il ya des tas de points communs
le foulard déjà chez vous sans doute
c'est un signe d'appartenance on
appartient à une collectivité à un
groupe une troupe une compagnie un
district une province ensuite l'ensemble
d'un signe qui indique nos fonctions et
un certain nombre d' un signe qu'ils
sont symboliques et qui représente
notamment plus important bien sûr est
celui de la promesse je ferais remarquer
que celui de christine est porté sur le
coeur puis à tout un ensemble de sade
toute une symbolique
le nôtre est porté sur la tête parce que
nous privilégions le
de porter notre un signe sur l'endroit
supposé de l'esprit mais le coeur est
très important aussi la preuve que nous
portons si notre racing sur le coeur et
notre porte aussi sur le ventre avec le
ceinturon puisque le scoutisme c'est
tout l'homme c'est le physique le coeur
et l'esprit
il n'a rien oublié non la description
est parfaite complaisent merci donc à
tous les deux d'être venu sur ce plateau
demain 22 février journée mondiale du
scoutisme merci à vous et internet soit
lui scout tous ceux qui sont scouts et
pour ceux qui le sont pas encore ils
sont cons bienvenus ces tendances d'être
scrutin vous nous l'avez dit c'est pas
désuet véritablement est de plus en plus
d'enfants qu'ils sont inscrits
environnement à présent avec ce chantier
du parc du foyer saint martin à montigny
le bretonneux en pleine réhabilitation
un chantier qui s'inscrit dans une
vocation écologique avec la réalisation
d'une mare notamment juin abou baker et
patrick jacques de dixmude pour les
images
les travaux ont commencé au parc du
courrier saint martin à montigny le
bretonneux une mare de 300 mètres cubes
est en construction l'aménagement et
écologique
le remplissage fait grâce à l'eau de
pluie le but en fait c'est qu'elle soit
alimenté de façon naturelle donc il ya
des nous qui vont être créés et on va
récupérer il ya une école derrière et on
essaie de récupérer les eaux de la
toiture et de la cour de récréation
le parc du foyer saint martin souhaite
installer la nature dans la ville
un jardin pédagogique créé en
partenariat avec la ligue de protection
des oiseaux accueillera une vingtaine
d'espèces dans des nichoirs et hôtels à
insectes sur une île parc est ouvert à
tout le monde
le l'espace
du jardin pédagogique sera un petit peu
protégés pour alerter vraiment les
visiteurs sur le fait que c'est un peu
de repos
inquiétude pour les animaux
et 1
à privilégier
cet espace dédié à la nature sera le
premier dans l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines
les travaux devraient être terminés le
28 juin et le parc disposera en plus
d'une mare d'une aire de jeu tout en
bois et d'un terrain multisports